I'm sure I'm a paranoid paranoid about
what well I have to worry about stuff
you know every to listen when the phone
rings too late at night or too early in
the morning I'm going oh my god in fact
if it stopped ringing I'd call everybody
I knew at work to find out what I miss a
lot it's gonna change when you think of
the u.s. being as close as it is to
energy sufficiency and now that they
have not having to be a net importer of
energy and you think of the history of
the last 40 years since the Arab oil
embargo when it really was driven home
how dependent we are on foreign oil and
all the way the history unfolded over
the last 40 years could you imagine how
different things would have been over
the last 40 years and can project
forward and imagine how different it
will be over the next generations if we
can get this right and make North
America energy sufficient both in terms
of the economy and in terms of the you
know the geopolitics in America's
position in the world it's quite a
blessing we have to reconcile the schism
between the people who are only thinking
in terms of the environment the people
who are only thinking in terms of
supporting the economy and get some sort
of accommodation between the two both of
whom are right but it's not a question
of you know one wrong one right both are
right but accommodation has to be
reached that we can go forward and have
rules that are durable and reliable so
people can make the kind of long-term
investments that allow us to receive the
benefits of of the energy situation and
those benefits are growth and jobs I
think it's hard enough to I think it's
hard enough to predict the present you
know to think about a perspective it's
very hard to step out of your context
and see what is happening
I have views about the future but I'll
tell you we're not in the business it
wouldn't be a very good risk manager if
you let what you think was going to
happen have too great an influence on
what you plan for and protect it against
what we really do is we really
contingency plan what might happen what
could happen the fact of the matter is a
number of people came to us afterwards
now this was this was the week after
Lehman Brothers when everybody was
fretting about whether the capital
markets were open and this was before
tarp and we did a transaction with the
Warren Buffett as you say which we did
preferred so then preferred and got five
billion dollars and the very next day
did did a common equity deal in the
market so the markets were open to us
and with Warren's money we got more than
just money we got the validation of
somebody who's regarded as a terrific as
a terrific investor and somebody who
knew our firm and that was an important
and Perimeter from him people called us
up afterwards and said gee I would have
done that and I think that would have
been great but with you I would I would
have just gotten another